okay that looks to be working let me
just get this stuff pulled up so I'm
really cutting it close on getting
everything going here right now because
I just I did something I very rarely do
this morning which was actually shut
down my computer completely as opposed
to just letting it go into sleep mode so
I did not recall that when I was getting
ready to set this up I'm like oh crap I
just actually need to start it up and go
through the entire friggin setup thing
not set up but like butta check its
itself and you know whatever the heck
else it does so this is this thing is
barely I could run the the livestream
even without the computer cuz I used my
phone but I use the computer to follow
the chat because trying to do that on
the phone - I learned the hard way
that's that's a pain in the butt product
placement
okay just finished listening to Bohemian
Rhapsody good morning hufflepuff in
Scotland checking oh yes it would be the
a.m. over there wouldn't it uh vitória
door in London ah come on back did you
like the latest episode of Game of
Thrones yeah I liked it pretty well um
and yeah like I put it in the name of
livestream up for talking um a throne so
spoilers abound nobody talk endgame
so help me God my vengeance will be
Swift um but yeah I like the latest Game
of Thrones pretty well I get at least
some of the reasons why some people
didn't like I got into a chat with was
somebody on discord who like the the
what seems to be the main issue at least
that I'm fine
with people who didn't like this one was
folks who got really invested in the
idea that it was going to not end well
and this felt like and like if you were
really committed to that this felt like
a bit of a cop-out episode in terms of
how few major main characters died I
think some people were really expecting
more of a bloodbath and those who didn't
get it felt like it was tau I wasn't
that invested in that and the idea that
it was gonna end unhappily so I was I
was cool with that Slytherin in Florida
Ned Stark dies Oh spoilers dude never
seen Game of Thrones it's not for
everybody but I've enjoyed it
he liked what he could see anyway yeah
fair point man that thing was dark it
was very reassuring to see that was a
common complaint oh good it's not just
me I didn't see my jewels too dark yep
yep yep hey Caroline a set no all the
regulars oh trans gamer girls boyo GOG
oh you like don't watch it who do you
think Sansa will end up with and will
she live I'd like to think that Sansa's
not gonna end up with anybody I think
after her being married off so many
freaking times that she'd just prefer to
stay single that's my ideal we'll see
like I would at this point I wouldn't be
shocked if they had her pair off with
Tyrion given what happened in the last
episode will she live uh yeah I think so
do you like the actor who plays Jamie
um he's he's good in that I haven't seen
him in anything else I'm always really
hesitant to label actors from a TV show
as good actors because I know from
experience that sometimes you just have
actors really well cast for a specific
TV role but then they play that role for
years and you think oh they're a good
actor but then you see them try and do
other stuff you realize oh they could
only do that one thing but I watched
them do it for years so I assumed they
were good at other stuff
they're not so I don't know I'm not
saying that's the case with him I'm just
saying if I only know someone from one
TV show I'm hesitant to label them good
actors because of fear of that I always
good see another ravenclaw yeah we got
we got a few of them around these parts
who is your favorite Marvel character um
like character like going all out that's
tough so like right up there would be
McGill O'Hara that spider-man 2099 um
Peter Parker mystique Squirrel Girl yeah
it's it is tough coming up with just one
especially if you expand beyond the
beyond the movies have you seen Hellboy
um I have not seen hell boy oh boy did
not play anywhere near me and given the
given the reviews that I saw I don't
think that's a big loss on my part
probably gonna have the mug up a lot
more this time I'm so subtle it's
amazing
suddenly a flying flying muffin it's
back um
I don't Fox mess with him but I love dr.
koop Doctor Doom in the comics is
awesome
so no complaint like I'm gonna I've got
a good podcasting friend Alan Middleton
who does the who does relatively geeky
and darkness light he's kind of best
known for the quarter been podcast he is
so into doom it's it's kind of awesome
if you've never checked out his podcast
stuff you should give that a listen so
enjoyed the link I sent you the other
day on Twitter
oh god that what did I ever do to you
that you send that to me like that was
cruel man that ah man that hurt and like
the thing was that's that was this okay
so if people don't know he sent me a
link for this Doctor Who weakest link
parody thing it hurt so much to watch
and it's totally the sort of thing that
normally I would watch thirty seconds up
and go nope I forced myself to watch all
like seven or eight minutes of it oh it
hurt it really hurt oh there it is I
knew the question was gonna come okay so
thoughts on the Sonic the Hedgehog
trailer haha oh boy so where do we start
with that thing hold on am I still going
did I
oh no though this thing just got stupid
on me on my okay so um the Sonic the
Hedgehog trailer is uh is the ninth
easiest thing that I have seen outside
of the 90s it's kind of insane how 90s
that they like from the ground up from
the room like the quality of the
animation to the premise of oh well
let's put them in the real world because
that sure worked for for Super Mario
Brothers and rocky and bullwinkle and
and Looney Tunes back in action like
wait when has the let's take this this
in human character and inject them in
the real world what has that ever result
in anything other than a terrible movie
at least in the 90s they had the excuse
of well we haven't done it that many
times maybe it'll work so like there's
that and then there's Jim Carrey at his
gym Carius but I I don't I don't
remember him being this Jim Carrey since
the Grinch movie like it's been a long
time since he's been this much Jim
Carrey
it like it was kind of amazing it's like
where did this come from
and like I looked into it
like the director the only other thing
he's ever directed was an animated short
about a gopher from 2004 that I actually
found and watched and it was okay it
wasn't there was nothing I like animated
shorts I'm a sucker for them and there
are plenty of animated shorts I've seen
more like I want to see what that person
does with more time more budget more
resources sometimes it doesn't always
work you can compare the original
animated short of 9 to the movie to see
how that doesn't always work but like
that's like yeah sure get that guy shot
but this you you wouldn't watch go for
broke and go let's give that guy a movie
15 years later it's kind of like the one
thing I did kind of smile eyeing up okay
was like the shot at the very end after
the title of Jim Carrey like with the
full proper like bald head and the
mustache out to here they're like okay
that's kind of funny to see but like not
not now I want to see the movie way like
in a it's just kind of an amusing image
kind of way it was really insane jim
Kerr was the wrong choice for dr. robot
again there's no chili dogs okay that's
pre-emptive I would not be shocked if
there are chili dogs in that movie
given how 90s the dang thing is oh my
god and engage disparities first of all
like what why why that choice of music
and then that just like all the more 90s
nostalgia Scalia Justice I getting
annoyed at Weird Al for parroting
gangsta's Paradise but he's totally cool
with it being on the trailer for Sonic
the Hedgehog we it was too serious for
Weird Al to parody but it's fine for
this what some nuts
ah I don't think there's gonna be a
night queen I were people expecting that
to happen I don't know anything about
Sonic the thing is I don't really what
little I know about Sonic I know through
osmosis I know because I've been in
various cultural things where sonic has
had a foothold you know I play video
games I've never really played Sonic I
read comic books I've never read Sonic
comics but I know they're a thing I
watch cartoons I've never watched the
sonic heard me but I know it's the thing
so like I've never been a part of that
fandom I've said that repeatedly but
sonic better talk about about sexual
harassment in the movie RL or else I
will hate it oh that's no good again
never even seen the show but I've seen
those clips Amish paradise yeah that's
the stuff there are so many better songs
for that than gangsta's paradise I mean
like I did it would be insanely easy to
come up with a massive list of stuff I
ran by flock of seagulls before
gangsta's paradise I would work did you
play Mario's kid oh yeah oh yeah
Nintendo kid growing up very much
did you see the flying muffins or in the
comments of the last year yes I did Oh
talk of grandbabies
that's cute I'm a ways off from having
to worry about that
I hope oh dear God ah but Megaman
Megaman wasn't real word yes in the real
world year of 20xx Game of Thrones book
fans were expecting the Knight Queen
because she was part of a story that old
man told bran about the White Walkers oh
okay well
at this point given how much was dropped
from the books they were expecting them
to pick up like a tiny thing that was
said by his nan like they've cut major
storylines but people thought that was
kind of [ __ ]
[Music]
to be honest the weirdness of the
trailer makes me want to see what has
been produced I'm not gonna read your
exact words but because I'm trying to
I'm gonna try really hard not to have
the archive of this live stream get
marked as not advertiser friendly
because that's happened not the last few
times in a row but it's happened twice
now that not only did they did did they
do that to me but like they confirmed on
a manual review no this isn't safe for
advertisers and I I'm not sure I can
even safely sit like I know why in both
cases I'm not sure I can even safely say
why because I'm afraid that even
mentioning it means this it'll happen to
this one again but yeah
stupidity did you read my comment I
which one like here in the chat or like
on a video cuz I probably I don't have
everybody's names memorized like I get
used to seeing oh what's on the what's
on your shirt oh it's uh it's a it's a
day of the doctor
sure so I've got I've got ten eleven and
the war doctor never be cruel or
cowardly never give up never give in
never give up never surrender
that's Doctor Who right I love good
train wreck so the thing is like I'm not
incapable of enjoying really bad
entertainment but like I need friends
who I can riff with and I need alcohol
and I can't do that in a theater so if I
ever have that kind of experience
watching something like Sonic it's gonna
be at home do you think stranger things
3 will be good
I hope stranger things 3 will be good
do I think it well I don't know I didn't
like stranger things too very much so I
don't know we'll see oh you're that
Coolio doesn't own gangsta's paradise I
mean I don't know for certain if that's
the case but I believe it knowing the
weirdness that goes on with with
copyright specifically in regards to
things like songs and whatnot so yeah I
mean I'd I'd buy that you need a list of
all your subscribers an alphabetical
order yes and I will then memorize it
and there will be a quiz and like no now
the question is what's the biggest
disaster sonic or Tom hoppers version of
the cat's music oh I forget that they're
doing him a cat's musical movie ah
here's what I would say hmm that's good
water
here's what I would say it was less of a
foregone conclusion that Sonic the
Hedgehog was going to you know or it is
but I mean let's be fair it's not having
yet it's less of a foregone conclusion
that Sonic the Hedgehog is going to suck
and if it does and as the potential to
suck in a way that will surprise you
because sometimes if you go in knowing
something's gonna be bad sometimes the
specific way that it's Bad's go okay I
didn't see that coming
but cats cats is a known quantity we
know how this is gonna suck cuz we know
how the music sucks we know how the
stage play sucks we know how the designs
of these things suck we know why cat
sucks so there's nothing interesting to
be had from that everybody drink is that
a gray pork that's Totoro man grape org
you go in the corner think about what
you did um pop quiz what's your 72nd
subscribers second middle name Janet
lady Mormont posthumously knighted oh
it's a lady Mormont
ah can they skip the cast movie and just
get to wicked the movie already I like I
enjoyed wicked I don't think it's gonna
work nearly as well as the movie as it
does as a stage play and if they were
gonna do it I preferred they would do it
animated but they're not gonna so anyone
noticed the knife are you used looks
like 13 sonic hmm interesting Katz is
such an odd creature how long it
survived them how it survived on
Broadway this long is bewildered
yeah I don't move I don't get it
I like the thing with with Kent like
Andrew Lloyd Webber's musicals in
general they're not good but I do find
some of it like I like Phantom of the
Opera I'm not sure I can actually say
that it's good but I like it
cats like I don't what what I do not
understand what the appeal is like at
all on any level I just don't get it the
only thing that trailer did was make me
wonder when we're getting a wily coyote
and Roadrunner live-action movie oh boy
don't give them ideas wicked starring
adele dazeem yes at least Phantom of the
Opera broke cats his record of longest
running show well yes between the two I
would much rather have it be Phantom
because at least I can give you reasons
why Phantom was successful riddle me
this
can you like Disney animated films
without liking musicals or vice versa um
yeah it depends on your own personal
baggage and hang-ups and headspace cuz I
mean I've known people who like have a
weird kind of a mental block for
live-action musicals they just can't do
this is the wilful suspension of
disbelief - by people bursting into song
but in animated form it's already so
unreal anyway that you know okay now
there's
singing - that's not a huge leap from
where you are so yeah I think it's
possible it's a little odd to me but no
I I could buy that
speaking of animation based on a comic
getting live-action versions the tix
series is amazing I mean I'm sure it's
fine I didn't like the first live-action
took all that much so I wasn't that
eager to see it tried together and like
I know it's different people doing it
and all that but like I like the cartoon
to me part of what works with the tick
is that potentially a truly bonkers
superhero thing could break out and my
presumption has been that they won't be
able to afford to do that in live-action
like live-action cannot afford to have
him climax an episode by fighting a
giant half news reporter half
mustachioed news reporter half dinosaur
but the cartoon good it's why the
cartoon was awesome I should say as
someone who performed cats I will say
this cats is more of a show that's fun
to be in rather than watch I'd buy that
I can see why actors would want to be in
it I just don't know why anyone would
want to see it I think when they get a
Nuke on now that was in reference to
something that I don't know what's going
on there so I'll move along can we get a
joker laughs and recognition of Dumbo
balmy at the box office that did make me
happy of course I get here that was the
first thing I hear there you go I think
sonic will be a good flash movie that
was weird that they like straight-up
aped quicksilver's iconic scene from
Days of Future past and also from
apocalypse but apocalypse sucks so the
hell with that yeah that was a little
odd and like what like why is his quill
electric that's not a thing is it yeah I
don't know Sonic well enough is that a
thing or is quills electric I don't
remember that
ah newest member of the Avengers gonna
be what's the point you already know
it's a flying muffin I've overused that
yeah you Andrew you are getting slightly
predictable uh what about a freakazoid
movie know if freakazoids ever gonna be
revived it should be in shorts and it
should be on the internet because that
is his true home he is a meme of Factory
and you do not try and stretch a meme
factory out to a feature-length film
just try and sit through the Aqua Teen
Hunger Force movie sometime
I haven't Lee imaginings uh
saw cats in high school I like the songs
but when I had to write a review for my
drama class I had the hardest time
trying to figure out what the plot was
just seemed like a lot of dust cats have
a plot I've actually never been clear on
that
freakazoid is awesome
no no would be amazing live actually
like I still I look I like freakazoid
but no not as not on not as a film I can
speak I want a Lord bravery movie I
don't know what that is
Animaniacs film live-action/animated go
get like okay what look so here's part
of my frustration with the Sonic the
Hedgehog movie because first of all let
me reiterate as far as Sonic himself is
concerned I don't care and that's not
like he's stupid and dumb like no I just
don't I have no investment I have no dog
in that race but I do have to wonder
like how do you look at that character
design and the world he lives in and the
things he does and not just make an
animated film I do CGI you know do
something a little different visually
with him if you want why would you ever
think to do that live-action and I keep
coming back to one of the elements in my
frustration when Disney's aren't going
live actually meant thing or
photorealistic live-action in the case
of the Lion King thing um but part of my
frustration with that is it reinforces
this idea that it's not a real movie
until it is live-action or gets to call
itself live-action and I hate that and I
feel like that that's part of the
mentality that led to this thing this
sonic thing being what it is because if
they just made an animated film for the
same amount of money they could have at
least had something that didn't have a
really stupid you know portal let's put
him in the real world plot and then have
all these actors just milling around
like they could have just made his world
and his friends and it's like why
wouldn't you do that and I just think
this engrained Oh cartoons aren't real
movies thing is like it's part of a
mental block for both executives and
some audience members and I hate that
the news okay so this is about the tick
new series is a lot better than the old
one it has the look and feel of a Marvel
DC show but the tip but with the ticking
friends and as for the insane enemies
dot dot dot mm-hmm the V LM very large
man is de 100 foot naked man that is a
big part of the story in season 1 and
LOB's Hercules is a giant humanoid
lobster version okay maybe I need to
give it a shot fair enough
I've always assumed cats the musical is
meant to be alive actually lying and
then they did the Lion King musical see
I've actually seen the Lion King musical
on stage it's amazing but it is very
much a stage show like it it does so
many things that you would only do in a
stage version like at the very start
during the circle of life song you have
these massive puppets but you know that
they're puppets like for instance there
is an elephant that goes down the aisle
towards the stage and like a full human
being is a leg of this thing as
it's moving its way down and it's
amazing but you can see you there like I
was gonna say transparent they're not
really but they're sort of cobbled
together and like it's almost like like
a scaffolding almost sort of thing so
it's like you're seeing the you see how
it works and it is amazing and it's very
stage II and it's something that you
would never do in a movie because you
want to hide those seams in a movie
whereas in theater you can embrace those
seams to make it a unique experience
so as dumb as Lion King on stage sounds
what they do with it was incredible but
for this stupid movie thing they're just
doing it again but now the characters
aren't expressive because it doesn't
look real enough so well or call it live
action it's just animated cough Lion
King cough cough yeah yeah it's based on
a book of poems but there is a plot oh
boy that's promising Capcom vs. Marvel
live-action movie oh dear
thoughts on Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood oh that's um that's Erin
Tino's next film right I'll probably see
it I think I've seen all of Tarantino's
movies Tarantino is one of those
directors where I'll see everything he
makes once I almost I think the only
Tarantino movie I've seen more than once
is um is Kill Bill Vol 1 I've seen more
than once I think that's the only one um
and now I kiss movies they're good I
just you know I don't need to watch them
more than once favorite musical I've
seen either little shop befores or
Avenue Q those are both very good both
of which I've seen I will Avenue Q S on
Broadway Little Shop of Horrors I saw a
community theater production but it was
a very good community theater production
there was a show that I saw when I was
in London called Blood Brothers which is
a really interesting show and it's it's
got really cool music and it's got this
real melancholy to it and the actors are
phenomenal because you get you get these
two adult actors
playing these characters from like seven
years old up through adulthood and it's
the same it's not like younger actor
Tina it's the same that it's the adult
actors even playing them at the young
age but they embody that youthfulness so
well that it works and your role with it
and it's kind of a an amazing show are
you a fan of Newsies I like king of New
York I was in I was in a number in a
drag troupe when I was in Brooklyn -
king of New York so I've got a soft spot
for that song specifically the film as a
whole
yeah and I've never seen the stage
version I'm I suspect it works better on
stage than it did on film I'm gonna go
out on a limb and and say that I love
the musical broad blood brothers are so
good my high school did a production of
it yeah I mean it's a great show it's
phenomenal what comic story would you
want to be adapted for the next Avengers
movie um I don't know because I haven't
seen any game yet so I don't know the
state of the MCU so without knowing that
I don't really have an answer to that
favorite musical Jeff Wayne's War of the
Worlds Tommy is the only musical I've
ever really enjoyed Tommy there are
elements of Tommy that I like it's kind
of pretentious for me but I haven't seen
hairspray lobby oh I did then Carolyn I
did see hairspray on Broadway and
playing the mother who's the name of the
character I cannot remember a book
playing Tracy's mother so in the
original hairspray it was divine in the
in the movie musical version it was John
Travolta playing that character when I
saw it on Broadway it was George Wendt
best known as norm from Cheers
he was so good he was so good Edna there
we go that's the character's name he was
so dang good in that it was phenomenal
I saw Christian Christian Kristin it's
just water
I saw kristin chenoweth in the apple
tree on Broadway she was a she was a
tiny speck when I saw it well I mean
like she is so tiny as a human being I
pretty sure unless you have like
orchestra seats you're not gonna see her
on stage I see lanes Rob in London I saw
I saw Lane is in um in New York when I
was in high school I also saw rent in
New York in high school when I that was
uh those in a chorus trip George went
I'd love to see that oh yeah he was good
yeah
norman hairspray was really amazing
water boring yes yes delicious water one
of my all-time favorite musicals is the
hunting of the snark I do not know that
one a lot of big names have played agna
Harvey Fierstein George Wendt Michael
McKean yeah Edna Edna is kind of the
stunt cast part because it's not
uncommon with Broadway musicals to get
one big name for one usually not the
lead role in a in a play and Edna is
kind of the role for that for hairspray
what's your favorite Harry Potter book
and movie I'm really need to rewatch the
movies to figure out what my favorite
movie is because I think it's um
half-blood prince my favorite book
that's easy that's Prisoner of Azkaban
so that one I know favorite movie I feel
like I need to relive them another
rewatch to solidify that but I think my
favorite movie is half-blood Prince I'm
gonna try to see Hamilton next year well
if you haven't gotten your tickets
already I think you can forget
next year maybe in 2021
the delicious water just got you to
monetize yeah quite possibly I wonder if
that's it like I wonder if they review
and think that I'm actually you know
chugging wine out of the wine bottles
other times I don't know whatever
we'll see this one gets to monetize so
as long as I don't talk about the stuff
that I'm pretty sure is what got me to
monetize the last couple live streams
then maybe that'll end up being at this
time we'll see
except I've done earlier ones we're like
I've used the flasks and stuff and like
in a shot glass not never got me to
monetize so I'm pretty sure it was topic
of conversation that was getting me
busted uh I rage I rage quit reading
Harry Potter after Prisoner of Azkaban
okay I feel like there's a story there
my favorite book is order of the Phoenix
cuz we went onto Luna I kind of hate
order order of the Phoenix the book I
really did not enjoy it
like I it's not that it's a bad book and
I the things that I don't like about it
I know why they're there and I know why
it's written the way it is I just don't
like reading it like at all
I really did not like that one does
lgbtq+ content still get demonetised
um no not automatically but depending on
what you talk about things that are
related to like talking lgbtq+ content I
think gets you more scrutinized for
stuff that might get you to monetize so
I think you just get more eyes on you
again that's my I've no proof of that
that's my experience though I think my
biggest regret for a Broadway show I
missed was the 2017 revival of Hello
Dolly starring Bette Midler and david
Hyde Pierce okay I don't even like Hello
Dolly that much but yeah that if you
could have gone to that you didn't
that's that's on you my friend
ah that would have been amazing
oh the I remember what I would one of
the things that I was gonna mention John
Singleton died director of many things
he did I'm boys in the hood was him mm
regrettably might have been the only
thing that he directed that I actually
saw but he had a stroke and passed away
within the last few days so that bummed
me out a little bit I've given up on
predicting what the hell YouTube will be
doing this week look here's the thing
about YouTube and this is true of the
algorithm this is true of what gets
monetized or D monetized this is this is
true of YouTube across the board they
don't talk to creators I mean they just
don't they do whatever they're gonna do
and we have and we like as a community
have to figure out what has gone on so
like anything you see about and here's
how the algorithm works we don't
actually know but this is what we've
figured out based off looking at how the
things behaving we have to reverse
engineer this crap because you do
YouTube doesn't talk to us like ever so
loved higher learning oh that one was
him - yeah question do you think Cersei
will win I'm worrying they're gonna do a
thing where the magical enemy is
defeated but the regular one can't be I
don't think she will cuz the thing is
like even if she has the means to take
down the now presumably weaken forces of
up Tyrion Sansa
Daenerys John and those folks her seat
of power is really precarious I mean you
know if you're on thought he could take
the throne he kill her knight in hot
second and it like even if she
quote-unquote wins I don't see her ever
be in a position where she is securely
on that throne so no I don't think so I
will say that I wouldn't be shocked if
the show has more main characters die
taking her down than did the night king
dishes cell war with HBO so I haven't
seen it for months
oh goodness see that that's one of the
reasons I'm so glad I got out of the
whole cable mess Thank You Tracy and a
good evening to you um I want a TV
reboot of the Kritters movie franchise
said no one ever
why so many of these remakes of these
terrible properties well couple of
reasons and also an know I haven't seen
Russian doll so the thing is for from
the perspective of any studio and this
is a studio of any size this is the only
the little ones or the major ones
anything that is an established name
anything that makes people go oh I've
heard of that is considered by
executives to if if you can get that
degree of recognition that is a form of
risk avoidance because making movies
again any movie of any budget size is a
risk because you may not make that money
back and knowing that you are making
something that is tied to something that
was successful once before whether it
was as a film before or in a completely
different medium that is a that is a
factor in risk management risk avoidance
so yeah these things that you're like
why is somebody dredging that up because
somebody somewhere said hey I've got you
know ten million I mean because 10
million is low-budget these days I've
got ten million dollars to blow on
either a movie or a 20 episode TV show
what franchise kind of get my hands on
that we'll work on that kind of budget
that I that is available oh hey critters
you know
they the these anything with name
recognition will never be allowed to die
I mean for that for that reason alone
how he pronounced as Cersei makes me
cringe oh I'm sorry
look I've pronounced it like 50
different ways over the years I probably
do it I probably still do it differently
look I'm sorry I I this happens to me
with other stuff too you know I get I
get called out from my pronunciation on
you know British terms when I talk
Doctor Who sometimes I'm like I this is
how I this is how I talk you got a deal
with it okay I don't know why I did that
I don't watch Game of Thrones but I'd be
cool with Peter Dinklage coming out on
top okay well here's the thing this is
for Liz in myself now that Lyanna
Mormont is dead cuz I wanted her on the
throne not even kidding
like I want bran he's about the only one
like in my mind that everyone's like who
ends up on the throne in my mind the
throne should not exist by the time the
show ends that like that throne gets
melted down with dragon fire that's my
that's my prediction and that's my hope
if it doesn't I want Bronn on that mofo
do you like Coraline bhai Neil Gaiman I
should even read the book I like the
movie I have not read the book as yet
it's okay still love you nice accent
yeah genuine New York accent just join
what are we talking about I don't know
with not oh no Jonathan it's bouncing
all over the place at this point have
fun everyone peace out watch out for
flying muffins for me personally the
female version of my name was my
cousin's name so that caused confusion I
mean that I forget where that came up
but somebody asked me why fer it might
have been the last
live stream and someone asked me for a
feminine name why don't use Natalie and
a big part of it why was when I first
started going out my at the time
girlfriend later wife and then you know
my daughter's mother her sister was
named Natalie and that was weird for her
for me to go by that in the process of
reading Coraline to my seven-year-old oh
that I mean you know your kid but I'm
like that's an Asian I'm like hope
they're okay with that like I was
nervous showing my kid the movie I mean
and she's seven um she dug it though and
she was cool she was good with it but I
I was nervous about that one I think
that might have been more of my hang-ups
though cause like what am I sort of
really recurring like nightmarish kind
of style fears has been somebody
replacing somebody this looks like
someone I know
but it's not them so like something like
the other mother kind of taps into that
a little bit it's part of why invasion
of the body snatchers the 70's version
is for me the scariest movie ever made
that's not the only reason why it's the
scariest movie ever made but it's part
of it did you take my advice and read a
few notes on the culture um I started to
look at it um and then I stopped and I
went back to the book because honestly
trying to read that blog post felt like
homework and I don't digest information
like that very well I picked up most of
what I'd read from context and if I get
to a point where I feel like I don't
know what's going on maybe I'll go back
to the blog post but I enjoyed picking
it up from context a heck of a lot more
than I like getting an information dump
like that and that's not a criticism of
you it that was I I appreciate you you
know trying to give me the best
experience for reading this book so you
know props to you for that I appreciate
it but just for how I like to digest
information I would much rather pick it
up from context then you know just just
read
this wall of conv back history and story
like Izone out I feel like I can read
them I'm reading a history textbook
question do you like the book well that
would be spoiling you gotta let me
finish it and put a review out wait your
turn
will you continue to go through the six
doctor and evylyn I mean I'm sure I'll
get some more of their stuff I'm not
doing you know the Big Finish stuff in
any order but I mean I'd certainly like
to I enjoy them a lot oh hey that was
okay that was cruel watership down is
definitely not for kids don't know how
it got a PG rating well at the time the
first one we got made I don't think
pg-13 existed yet I'm pretty sure that
that movie predates pg-13 and a lot of
things that you were like wait what got
PG back then it was kind of a kind of an
odd time what is it what is your opinion
on Eternal Sunshine of the spotless mind
it's my favorite movie I really need to
re-watch it cuz I've only seen it the
ones I did really liked it though it's
incredibly well constructed and it's
real it's a it's a wonderful mindscape
of a film it's really well put together
and it has a lot of interesting insights
into relationships and the way they
progress and dynamics between people and
the performances are great it's it's a
really good movie I haven't seen it in
ages but it is quite good
have you heard the six doctor's
regeneration story Big Finish it no I
have um so yeah I know that that exists
it's a box set though isn't it like cuz
it's like last adventure or something
and it's one of the box set things and I
like the box sets but they're freakin
expensive so I'm still trying to try to
keep my my finances I'm
trying to recover from paying taxes so
that's it kind of puts me in a in a
place where I'm watching my wallet more
than I might otherwise always meant to
watch Eternal Sunshine if you haven't
seen it I recommend it I mean it's it's
it's a little head trip II it's a little
sci-fi II but like if that's kind of
your bag at all definitely check it out
let's see so I haven't caught a stream
before but I want to say your content
has helped me be more open-minded I
don't really understand agree with all
lifestyles but respect you and think
you're great Thank You Cody I it's funny
every now and then people will ask me
sometimes in the context of like how do
I come out to somebody in my life but
other times I've had people ask me you
know or or I've seen people asking in
general the question of you know how do
you how do you talk to and how do you
change the minds of people who don't
understand and take issue with you know
the life of somebody like me and the
thing is I don't think you can apply
direct pressure to try and do that but
what I do think helps is - is for them
to just get to know somebody with a
different experience and ideally
probably the most effective is you know
somebody in their real life but failing
that you know if if my talking about you
know the gender-fluid aspects of my life
intermittently amongst all the geeky
stuff that maybe people are here for
that primarily I like to think it
normalizes somebody like me to them and
they go oh well it's not like this weird
bizarre thing that's a geek okay I can I
guess that's not so weird and so I like
to think that just sort of that kind of
immersion is helpful I think is probably
the best way to gradually wear down that
wall that that some people have tended
to
I don't know if that was necessarily the
case with you Cody but I do appreciate
you expressing that get them to watch
contra points that - that works like the
very very video today thank you that one
I'm trying to do at least a one video on
the variwatt handle a month so new one
went up today I was pretty proud of that
one that that went well I love learning
about some ways of living yeah I think
it's if if you get the chance to to
learn it's it's a great thing
what's your pronouns everybody drink um
my pronouns I don't care I mean the
reality is my pronouns are completely
situational depending on my own
headspace but I don't expect anyone to
keep up with my own shifts so I say just
go with whatever feels right
and I it doesn't bother me it's cool
that you're trying to normalize gender
fluidity and cetera well I'm not it's
not like a goal to normalize it
I like I'm I'm just being me I'd like to
think that maybe at least for some of my
audience
it's an upshot of what I do but I don't
want to say that it's it's like
something that I'm actively trying to do
who because it's it's not like this is
my agenda but um you know I'm just hey
I'm here that's if you want to get big
finished cheaper you should keep an eye
out for their sales yeah I do I I do
watch for their sales listen to the pun
they have a podcast oh I did not realize
there was a big finished podcast I will
take a look at that okay it's not aware
philosophy tube is awesome I've seen a
little bit of their stuff um it's pretty
good running out of wine
I need to head out night gravy screams
on No thank you for stopping in it was
good to see you as it always is seems
like everyone in the north is okay with
women dressing like men does it bug you
very much wasn't like that when G ot
started not sure I entirely follow the
question oh okay so on Game of Thrones I
don't know I hadn't really been tracking
the gender stuff on Game of Thrones and
I think I think it just did something
that most shows tend to do over time
which is if you establish early on in
the history of the show that something's
like weird and unusual but like your
characters do it a lot eventually you
stop having them get hassled for it
because the audience is going yeah we've
seen this already and it doesn't
necessarily mean that the world the
story takes place and has changed it
just means they did that story enough
that it's not worth them rehashing and
they just kind of move on from it and I
suspect that's kind of what happened
with Game of Thrones in regards to that
kind of thing
I just used a it's the same it's the
safest as I can't how that tell how they
identify at any time especially this
presentation does not always equate to
identity and that works like I'm okay
I'm okay when they I don't I don't
generally request it but I'm totally
cool with a um like didn't I just don't
call me it don't call me a thing you do
that we're gonna big issues but as long
as you don't do that like it's fine
whatever you want to go with us fine we
know no king but the king that is stark
Briana's a southerner no one has treated
her like a lady till Jaime I'm come
I'm confused what is gender-fluid ho oh
boy strap in okay so gender fluid is and
it it is how I personally identify and
so it is part of the
trans umbrella because trans is meant to
be an umbrella term now most people know
trans as meaning either trans woman
someone born as a man who transitions
into life as a woman or a trans man
someone born as a man and then
transitions I did it I might have done
it backwards you trans woman starts as a
man becomes a woman trans man starts as
a woman becomes a man most people are
familiar with that the thing is though
is they're the first thing you need to
realize is that gender is not a binary
male and female are not the only two
options on the gender spectrum there's a
million things in between the comparison
I like to make is it's a light switch
versus a dimmer switch most people think
of gender in terms of light switch it's
got two settings you know on or off
male/female but gender is more like a
dimmer switch where it can be all the
way on it can be all the way out but
there's a little million tiny variations
within and that's where you get
non-binary identities that's where most
of the people who go with a them
pronouns tend to exist in that area in
between someone who is gender fluid it
is what it sounds like my sense of
gender doesn't stay put I I see I I
hesitate to ever say firmly that I
identify as a woman at times but I there
are times where I feel very distinctly
feminine in myself and I wish to express
myself in a feminine way it's not just a
manner of putting on feminine clothes
that would just be cross-dressing which
I used to identify as till I sort of
came to a better understanding of myself
over time so um the the whole thing with
gender fluidity is just I am free to let
my sense of self wander to wherever it
ends up and sometimes that's more
masculine sometimes it's more feminine
sometimes it's that a weird place in
between but like I don't there's um
there's a lot of misconceptions about
like anything other than trans woman
trans man like there's misconceptions
about them as well don't get me wrong
but I think most people at this point
understand the basic premise
the trans woman or trans man because
that still fits the gender binary
because he started when you go to the
other so there's still only two options
it doesn't break the foundation of the
foundational understanding of only two
genders the way that the way that gender
fluidity or non-binary identities do
so those act like you'll even within the
trans community you'll get people who
give grief to non-binary and gender
fluid and genderqueer identities because
it challenges a lot more fundamental
thinking and I'm not saying that like in
a way that like I'm proud of that I'm
not I'm not out to try and challenge
anybody's conceptions of anything I'm
just trying to live in a way that makes
me feel fulfilled it's my life
it's pronouns for AI entities are one of
the things that tell me progressive or
not the in banks was a person with a
1970 Haiti understanding of gender which
happens I mean the thing is like it's
it's hard to it's difficult to ask
people to keep evolving their
understanding past a certain point
there's a reason that the younger
generation is always the more
progressive one relative to the older
generation cuz I think is a very human
thing that eventually you get to a point
where you're just like I understand the
world or at least I think I do and you
kind of want the world to stop changing
cuz you don't want to have to keep
learning stuff you want to just kick
back and relax and enjoy your golden
years and I think that's part of why
there's the natural inclination for
older generations to be more
conservatives because they they just
want the world to stop changing so that
they can enjoy it but the world doesn't
stop changing society doesn't stop
changing our understanding of people
doesn't stop changing and it's
exhausting to try and keep up with so I
I get where the resistance comes from
like as it has a basic human reaction to
things but you know it results in a lot
of BS not being a busybody open to my
mind
ie maturity it's interesting how broader
society's knowledge of gender is just
now waking up to these identities that
have probably been around forever
oh yeah like that's the other thing is
that people get on this sort of thing
where they think oh all these new things
this didn't used to happen well no it
did but two things the first is people
with non-standard gender identities used
to have to keep that to themselves for
purposes of safety because depending on
what area you lived in it got you beaten
up beaten up or committed to an asylum
or burned at the stake or what-have-you
but even beyond that like people have
had these feelings in these senses of
being wrong and not
being the thing that they're assigned at
birth biological gender and biological
sex is telling them they should be but
there wasn't language for that there
wasn't a conversation about that there
wasn't an understanding about it
so it's like how it's a common
misconception that we have way more
diagnosis of autism than we used to and
that's true but only insofar as our
understanding of what autism is means
that a lot of behaviors that before just
got brushed off as that guys kind of
weird now has diagnosis and a name it
doesn't mean that we have more instances
of autism it just means we are able to
identify it better so it's kind of the
same thing with the gender thing like
people like me have always been around
we just haven't had the nerve to talk
about it and haven't always had the
words with which to talk about it so
there you go are you a fan of Oscar
Wilde I am oh I like Oscar Wilde stuff
and I know that was directed at somebody
else but I do like his sentence I enjoy
clever wordplay ish style comedy I think
it it holds its Sun and some of the
comedy that holds up better because
comedy ages badly I think possibly more
than any other genre comedy age ages
really the Internet has allowed all
social movements to occur faster and
with more visibility um yeah and that
and that's for good and ill because the
people pushing things in a progressive
direction can move the conversation
forward faster but the people who are
reactionary towards that and want to
stop it
they can amass you know how they want to
tackle it faster as well so it cuts both
ways like via the internet like every
major technological advance isn't of
itself a relic
simply neutral thing that is capable of
both good and bad depending on what we
do with it on the one hand cute cat
videos on the other hand Nazis are back
I'm impressed with your self-awareness
I'm I'm a fairly self-critical person in
general but like one thing that I do
kind of pride myself on is a decent
level of awareness so thank you
which would you rather see first a
second lady doctor or a first trans
doctor um I don't like the reason I'm
about to give this answer but it's just
the reality of where things are right
now right now I right now at this point
in time I would rather see a second
female doctor because I don't have the
heart of the stomach right now to deal
with what the reaction would be to a
trans doctor it's something I would like
to see but I just I just don't have it
in me to deal with it right now to deal
with what what the backlash would be oh
that was another thing that I meant to
bring up so coming back to Game of
Thrones and speaking of backlash good
because I brought this up on Twitter I
mean I'm only gonna vent this here so
that I don't have to devote a video to
it cuz if I don't talk about it here
I'll probably feel like I I have to UM
and man oh whoa sorry hold on what's it
the doctor's gender-fluid no maybe we
don't know how much of a how much the
gender changes a choice if it's not if
it's not a true shift in sense of self
and it's just a physical change
we don't really know enough about it
arguably maybe but anyway so coming back
to Game of Thrones it was weird like if
I were to do a video on it it would have
been it would be another citation needed
which I've only done once before and
that was last year I think when um when
Kathleen there were like it was a big
thing with people saying that Kathleen
Kennedy called people who don't like
Star
racists and bigots and misogynist
how dare she insult the fans and then I
tried to source that and couldn't find
it anywhere but there was all this
outrage over her saying this what she
never said and I I've gone through a
similar thing with in reaction to the
Game of Thrones episode Oh
all these butthurt man babies I'm
paraphrasing what people are saying does
not necessary my positions well all
these butthurt man baby's calling Arya
Stark a Mary Sue and then all this
outrage about these people who are mad
that that people are calling Arya Stark
or Mary Sue here's the problem and I
even put a call out on Twitter asking
for people to source me some of this
I've got a handful like for tweets that
I've seen that actually make an argument
that she's a Mary Sue I've seen it come
up in a couple of responses to people
who are outraged that people were
outraged and but those I look at those
accounts a lot of those instances I'm
like you have existed for a month
you have zero followers and only follow
14 people you do nothing but retweet
like these are all suspect accounts so
I'm not gonna say that nobody said it
cuz like again I felt like I've been
source like four instances but I and I
look I found all these articles
debunking this idea that Arya is a Mary
Sue and even in these articles like from
decent usually decent outlets Internet
outlets they would say there's an
average on the Internet and usually when
I go to something like that I can count
on the article write-ups about it to
source me saw your screenshot me some
original tweets that they're basing on
top of and none of them do if they
source anything it's just the ones that
are mad that people said it but not any
of these is being said the Guardian had
one link to a reddit thread that had
three comments and a zero score like
it's become a manufactured outrage like
even even if you can find me more
instances at this point by far the
instances of people being outraged that
people thought that people called her a
Mary Sue far exceeds any instances of it
actually happening and I find the whole
thing really frustrating because this
kind of reaction is it's what it's what
the other side says we do which is to
have this major outrage over something
very minor and we've now literally just
done that like people who generally fall
aligned with perspectives than I tend to
agree with have lost their mind over
something that almost nobody actually
said it's just really frustrating
because I said this I said this in a in
a video on the veera channel that when
it comes to the perception of
progressives that more conservative
people have the problem is not what we
are it's what they think we are
but then stuff like this feeds into what
they believe us to be and it's and it's
a fairly standard confirmation bias
thing like people heard Oh
male fans of Game of Thrones are mad
that Arya Stark killed the night King
and think she's a Mary Sue and because
it confirms a thought they already have
in their head like oh yeah there are
totally fans that are like that and
there are don't get me wrong but they
immediately assume the truth in it
rather than checking out which as so far
as I can tell almost nobody's bothered
to do and it's just been really
frustrating and I'm sorry for eating up
like the whole tail end of the
livestream video
I said I needed to vent that out of my
system cuz if I didn't do it here I'd
end up devoting a whole video to it I
don't think I want to but I would have
had to like to just to cleanse myself of
it very happy that Nathaniel gets this
critically observe vent for articles
arguments and articles on both side
shows good judgment I mean like at this
point I just anytime there is any sort
of outrage about something that somebody
said I just want original source like I
will always go to that um whether
whether what I'm hearing is something
that I'm inclined to believe or not like
just show me the original source because
I know oh that it the Internet is a game
of telephone
boy I show my age with that is that a
reference that people even know anymore
but you know somebody says this and you
hear it and then somebody hears it from
you and it gets distorted every step of
the way so you always got to go back to
the original source and if you can't
find one there you go I assume someone
just said it mockingly and it was taken
as fact I mean that's possible like I
said I have seen like a couple of
instances like for three or four of
people who did seem to be making that
argument genuinely have you seen Shazam
I have not it's no longer playing and
the town where I am I didn't get to it
initially so I'll probably see it
eventually have I seen that game No shut
your mouth
I have not Chinese whispers yeah that's
another term for the same thing I know
telephone I'm old yep so that's the end
of my water
so that might be my cue to wrap it up um
she stole jon's destined to kill I mean
how much has the show actually gone in
for destiny though like it it's and and
the show overall has been very big on
undercutting what was expected so I mean
I've had her like if if you were
invested in the idea that John was gonna
kill then I can't I get being
disappointed in that that's fine that's
fair enough is have you seen an endgame
a short question now it could have been
for this one I mean come next week
stream I will have seen it it's fine
that she killed them the issue is her
jumping out of nowhere is the issue well
different people have different issues I
have no issue personally but some people
have certain issues with actually
various elements but I don't want to I
don't want to go through who and um you
know point for point with every and
every given thing especially considering
I'm trying I'm trying to wrap up here
have a good one gotta watch the Orval
and are your rules very cool
thank you squeak no one makes videos
upset about Gary Stu's yeah yeah they
don't they just don't but
does that mean I need to skip next week
stream them as no well I've seen endgame
I they you might need to I mean look if
I think I'm gonna talk to endgame
spoilers I'll actually make that the
name of the stream the way I did with
Game of Thrones spoilers for this one so
you'll have your fair warning but yeah I
mean it's at least for me it's gonna
even if it's not something I'm gonna be
talking about next week it'll be on the
table because I'll have seen it um do
you like The Hobbit and Lord of the
Rings I like The Hobbit book and the
Lord of the Rings movies I hate The
Hobbit movies I love the rankin/bass
animated one by hateful live-action
Hobbit movies and I am kind of bored by
the Lord of the Rings novels so haha
there you go how'd you feel about the
dragon fire not killing the night king I
was fine with that like we we don't know
much about this guy so I'm totally cool
with his power set being something that
we just did not know happily enjoy my
time Oh yep that was sorry no I'm
jumping in on other people's
conversations alright yeah I'm gonna I'm
gonna write where there's a whip there's
a way Shh okay we're gonna end it there
so thank you all for tuning in I hope
you have had a decent week I am actually
yeah I'm gonna do one quick bit of
editing and I'm gonna go to bed because
I had a real hard time getting up this
morning and I feel like I need at least
an additional hour of sleep versus what
I usually get so hope everyone has a
good one and have a great weekend new
overdue Doctor Who review tomorrow and
I'll see you all later have a good one
thanks everybody uh